мара рикуна на лад століття і рідна мова
латвія проте вражає нікшні росіян і в
штабі 6 учим біля кафе морозу зустрічається з
олексієм vintage громадян латвії алла
відмінний русский і теж його рідна русь
k-maro відома співака який же виступала
за свою Україну на і включатися не
олексій фотограф он і добрий зрозуміло
ми розбавляємо латвійську зимувати тому
а я почала олексій з ввічливості ланцюга
прямо у нас молоді
34 молодці необхідність з телком
нормально але одна де старшим поколінням
ситуаціях цим ш
марат часто стікається з рецидивом
російського панування був іду в магазин
з вертайся латвійську ви не хочеться б
я говорила російську із ситуації акулу
monavie трохи а що неправильно а так і
стояти за часто віджимання ромашкою в
районі рада живуть одні russian і вату
злих би знання латвійське без паспорта
без роботи
джерело інформації російською польщею
канал латвійському пригнічувало канал і ніхто
за них надіватися
вище петлі анексії крима влада
зведу мало небес pq путінської
пропагандою та за проведення випуску новим
теж російську алли члени запис але мені
здається ніколи не пізно робити крок
назустріч ми не здаєте ніколи написано
руб це коло на зу стригти очікування
вигодою викарбував продовжить хочуть і
п'яті руки на створення свого ЗМІ для
російського для дачі вигляд утворився і
на нас і на спинку ваня з нашою
аудиторії на
нашому спілкуванні з нашою аудиторією ціни
єдиної російської мови на інформаційний
ресурс для популярний інтернет портал
медуза кілька рук у тому
у складі 20 ма дейнеки в Росії приїхавши
самий сюди ми ду зарубати ставку на
молоду аудиторію та надаж листи путіна
та й дон поштою нав'яжемо дати війни мол ті
покоління в Росії більше вони дівиця
або Дженні атома для кремлівської
пропаганди геть і завищуються треба
сильними
ct він не лякає а той же не пута їх не
телевізійний контент тебе важливі
велика та активно частини населення не спа
жива
port saeed і дайте про такий хліб
олексій і к і форму і свою думку
анапе tv play вам російською
пропаганди пін пуделя я рідко відомий
пісні мари c часті нарив і моїй рибі
складної риби до простої частини нові
і
[музика]